offenbar ist Olaf Scholz ein sehr
bescheidener Mensch er habe bei der
Kabinettsklausur geradezu sinnlich
erfahren wie gut die Ampelkoalition
funktioniere selbst wenn es zischt und
kracht der Kanzler bleibt genügt
genügsam und eben sinnlich ob damit die
Ampel auf Dauer in ruhigen Fahrwasser zu
halten ist ist eine ganz andere Frage
und die ist angesichts der vielen Krisen
kriegsentscheiden die Bundesregierung
muss sich bewähren in konstruktiver
Zusammenarbeit sonst steht uns das
Schlimmste noch bevor
Krach oder Kuschelkurs Koalition in
schweren Zeiten jetzt in der Phoenix
Runde
[Musik]
Phoenix Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
hier im Studio jasmin ist bei uns von
ZEIT ONLINE
Nadine Lindner ist Hauptstadt
Korrespondentin für den Deutschlandfunk
Albrecht von Lucke Publizist und
Redakteur der Monatszeitschrift Blätter
für deutsche und internationale Politik
und Robin Alexander stellvertretender
Chefredakteur der Welt ist auch hier
alexander hat die Ampel in meseburg
eigentlich geliefert was sie bis dahin
liefern konnte war das zu viel war das
über das genügend was da bereits
beschlossen also die haben sich
getroffen und
Teambuilding betrieben und paar Dinge
besprochen eine digitalstrategie
erarbeitet und solche Dinge aber das
worauf alle warten das Entlastungspaket
das kommt ja erst nächste Woche war aber
für Meseberg auch noch gar nicht
angekündigt von daher das ist jetzt so
wie sie haben ja wahrscheinlich heute
morgen auch eine Konferenz mit Ihrer
Redaktion gemacht aber trotzdem ist die
Sendung entscheidend und nicht wie gut
sie sich in der Konferenz verstanden
haben und vor allem bei der ist die
Ampelkoalition eigentlich überfordert
ich würde sagen zu teilen zu Rechte
überfordert ist es natürlich eine
Koalition die von Anfang an durch Krisen
geprägt ist von Afghanistan über Corona
bis hin zum derzeitigen Krieg in
gewisser Weise aber schon überfordert
weil man das Gefühl hat es muss nicht
nur es muss nicht nur Lösungen gefunden
werden sondern auch wie schon
angesprochen eine Art Mediation
stattfinden da man sich in Krisenzeiten
ja auch
öfters mal in die Haare bekommt und
vielleicht auch um professionell agiert
Habeck hat ja Olaf Scholz auf offener
Bühne in den Himmel gehoben kann man
fast sagen also jedenfalls für Koalition
ohne Koalitionäre in den Himmel gehoben
wie gut das Olaf Scholz diese Regierung
führt hat er gesagt war das ein
vergiftetes Lob oder haben sich da zwei
aneinander festgehalten die im Moment
kein allzu guten Lauf haben nein das war
keineswegs vergiftet das war wenn man es
mal so formulieren will die Einsicht in
die Notwendigkeit
Robert habecks und das war ja eine
bemerkenswerte Äußerung das quasi der
Mann der gegenkanzler förmlich ist der
von vielen auf seiner kommunikativen
Fähigkeit als der eigentliche
Kommunikator dieser Koalition
wahrgenommen wird dass er derartig sagt
wir brauchen die Ernsthaftigkeit von
Olaf Scholz er hat sich gewissermaßen
zurück ins Glied genommen und das muss
man sagen war dem Umstand geschuldet
dass diese Koalition davor ein Hauen und
Stechen gezeigt hatte die Tatsache dass
man muss sich das bewusst machen der
Parteivorsitzende SPD Lars Klingbeil
ob das durchaus groben Fehlers von
Robert Habeck was die gasumlage
anbelangt spöttisch und hämisch sagte
die Kommunikation ist nichts es kommt
auf das Ergebnis an und damit natürlich
einen solchen Schuss tätigte ob der
enormen rankingwerte von Habeck im
Gegensatz zu den desaströsen Werten von
Scholz was dann die Konsequenz hatte das
Konstantin von Notz der Vize
Fraktionsvorsitzende frontal aber in
einem Maße Frontteil den Kanzler
angeschossen hat er könne nicht seine
miserable Performance seine miserabel
Umfragewerte seine angeschossenheit in
der cum-exaffäre könne er nicht jetzt
illoyal am Klima Minister außerdem das
hat habe ich glaube völlig zu Recht zu
sagen ich muss zurück ins Glied ich muss
gewissermaßen kenntlich machen wenn wir
jetzt nach einem Jahr uns in permanenten
selbstzerstörerischen Attacken
gegenseitig bewegen dann wird diese
Koalition kein gutes Land erleben aber
es war ausgehend das muss man klar sagen
von einer frontalen Attacke auch das sp
Parteivorsitzenden und daran sieht man
dass von der Eintracht sich schrieben
das so schön sinnlich erfahrene Harmonie
gegenwärtig meinem Eindruck nach nicht
die Rede sein kann das war eine
Beschwörung wie lange die hält das wird
man sehen Frau Lindner ist der Glanz der
Ampel dahin na ich glaube das wird sich
zeigen also die Ampel ist
herausgefordert in einer eine politische
Konstellation die sehr ungewöhnlich ist
in politisch ungewöhnlich schwierigen
Zeiten also dass dort
schwierige Entscheidung getroffen werden
müssen die sich auch wo auch
verschiedene Parteien verschiedene
Fraktionen Kröten schlucken müssen was
kein Spaß macht das geht damit einher
ich habe Meseberg auch ein bisschen so
wahrgenommen dass man versucht zu diesem
Spirit zurückzukommen dass wir eine
fortschrittskoalition sind das ist ja
auch oder dass die Ampeln eine
fortschrittskoalition ist und das ist ja
heute auch noch mal von Rolf Mütze nicht
dem Fraktionsvorsitzenden in Dresden
beschworen worden der gesagt hat bei dem
was wir jetzt Vorhaben im
Koalitionsausschuss das dritte
Entlastungspaket das muss mehr sein als
die Summe von verschiedenen kleinen
Kompromissen das muss mehr sein als der
kleinste gemeinsame Nenner das muss ein
rundes Bild ergeben also das heißt man
hat die Latte jetzt relativ hoch gelegt
ich glaube schon dass der Glanz ab ist
aber in Zeiten wo in der direkten
europäischen Nachbarschaft ein
Angriffskrieg geführt wird finde ich
persönlich das auch nicht sonderlich
überraschend Alexander es ist ja sind ja
nicht nur schwere oder schwierige
Herausforderungen sind ja auch viele
schwierige Herausforderungen auf einmal
laufen zum Teil parallel
jagen sich gegenseitig sozusagen in der
Aktualität ist das Krisenmanagement der
Ampel an diese Situation dieser vielen
dieser multiplen Krisen und auch zum
Teil schwerwiegenden Krisen angepasst
also das ist ja eine Sache die in der
Spitze auf erstaunlich wenige Personen
zuläuft nämlich auf drei Scholz Lindner
und Habeck und die müssen auch viel
weniger als früher mit ihren Fraktionen
rückroppeln also machen ja einiges mit
diese Fraktion und von daher sind sie da
schon eigentlich für schnelle
Entscheidungen gut aufgestellt nur
schnelle Entscheidungen müssen ja nicht
immer richtig sein und zum Beispiel bei
der gasumlage hat man ja gesehen da hat
man einfach mal Dinge Dinge falsch
gemacht Dinge falsch gesehen ich glaube
übrigens nicht dass das nur habe ich war
und das ist glaube ich in der
Kommunikation von der SPD extra so
gelenkt worden in Wirklichkeit waren die
da auch im Boot und da
kommen die nicht immer auf die richtige
Höhe und das ist vielleicht tatsächlich
weil es so eine Krise ist schwierig
andererseits regieren ist halt auch ist
auch schwierig ja das ist natürlich auch
jetzt ist der Beweis ob sie es richtig
gut können oder nicht und ich finde bei
Scholz ist ja noch mal besonders zu
stellen weil heute ist ja ein Politiker
der mit dem Anspruch antritt Handwerk
ist alles also alles was er ausstrahlt
ist ja ich kann regieren ich war schon
jeder Minister und Finanzen und ich kann
das und so und wenn man sich so ganz auf
die Sachlichkeit und auf das Handwerk
fokussiert dann kann man natürlich auch
Fragen stellen wenn es mal nicht
funktioniert ja gut könnt ihr auch ein
Spiel mitverteilten Rollen sein das eine
das Handwerkliche dann für die Show für
die Performance ist dann der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister zuständig der
Finanzminister Spielern seine eigene
Rolle ist diese dieses sein Spiel mit
verteilten Rollen ich glaube das war es
ich finde dass der Angriff von Lars
Klingbeil eigentlich zeigt dass es
sozusagen die die
Prestige Seins Habeck die Lorbeeren
abzuflöten als Scholz nach Kriegsbeginn
so in der Kritik stand das sozusagen die
Rückkopplung ist auch mal seitens des
Kanzlers als Parteivorsitzender zurecht
zu sagen
dort wurde mit Ehrlichkeit gepunktet man
hat sich mit den Grünen profilieren
können im Sinne von das gute Gewissen zu
sein seit Kriegsbeginn und jetzt sieht
man es gibt auch Entscheidungen die der
Wirtschaftsminister falsch treffen kann
und da dieses geschlossene Bild in
Meseberg jetzt auch zu sagen dann
arbeitet zu dritt miteinander und es
geht eigentlich darum wer da alleine
vorne steht und ist für mich eher das
Zeichen dass man
bestimmte Aufgaben schon verteilt aber
eigentlich geschlossen wirken möchte
eine fehlt noch den wir noch mal
vielleicht genauer ansehen müssen den
Bundesfinanzminister wenn dem etwas
nicht passt in der Koalition sagte steht
nicht im Koalitionsvertrag
gut jetzt können wir sagen gut dann ist
die Sache für mich erledigt wird
wahrscheinlich wenig bringen muss der
Koalitionsvertrag neu geschrieben werden
nein ist glaube ich nicht der
Koalitionsverträge sind ja immer ein
Spiegel ihrer Zeit
diesen Spiegel der Ideen die sich
verschiedene vor allem auch Parteien
Fraktionen
zusammengefunden haben hat ja auch dann
was in die Zukunft gerichtet ist ich
finde natürlich muss man konzertieren
dass dieser Koalitionsvertrag nicht
angesichts einer veränderten
wirtschaftlichen einer veränderten
sicherheitspolitischen Lage von einer
ganz anderen Folie spielt deswegen finde
ich dieses Argument diesen Hinweis
darauf da steht nicht im
Koalitionsvertrag eigentlich ein
bisschen wohlfeil mein Eindruck ist so
ein bisschen man kann das dann irgendwie
spielen man kann das dann irgendwie
ziehen gerade wie es einem passt wenn
man sich vielleicht um das politische
Argument dann
rundherum drückt weil auch die 100
Milliarden Euro zum Beispiel für die
Bundeswehr die standen ja auch nicht im
Koalitionsvertrag drin und man muss dazu
sagen es wird halt einigen Stellen ist
es auch schwierig weil bestimmte bei
bestimmten Dingen zum Beispiel ein
Klimaschutz bleibt der Koalitionsvertrag
auch extrem schwammig so dass er dann
halt auch keine auch auch nicht die
Leitlinie sein kann die man sich
vielleicht auch Anführung in
Anführungszeichen nochmal in normalen
Zeiten dann davon erhofft
ich glaube schon dass die Tatsache dass
diese Koalition nie eine richtige
Antwort auf den 24 Februar dieses Jahres
gegeben hat das entscheidende Problem
ist der Koalitionsvertrag hatte eine
Geschäftsgrundlage und die war ganz klar
formuliert wir wachsen ohne jeden
Abstrich weder für die besser situierten
noch für die Schwächeren gewachsen in
ein Regime einer wie hieß es so schön
einer sozialökologischen Transformation
rein das sollte gleichermaßen
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer
bedienen wie aber auch die Kapitalseite
die Arbeitgeber Beispiel
Automobilindustrie wir machen eine
fundamentale Erneuerung zum Strom Auto
also zur Elektrizität das was passiert
aber immer auf einer Grundlage die war
ganz klar ist basierte auf der
vorübergehenden Lösung mittels
russischen Gases und in dem Augenblick
da das weggefallen ist hat und das ist
natürlich ein hauptversagen auch das
Kanzlers diese Koalition nie zu einer
neuen Grundlage gefunden und da gab es
jetzt für die FDP 2 Möglichkeiten die
eine Möglichkeit und der gegen die
verwahrt sich Lindner mit Händen und
Füßen wäre zu sagen wir passen Strategie
ein Stück weit an ich sehe zum Beispiel
hätte ja hinten auch sagen können die
Notwendigkeit unter einer so harten
brutalen Lage ich sehe die Notwendigkeit
auch mit stärkeren Entlastung für sozial
Schwache die ja in diesem Jahr
vielleicht noch über die einstellige
Paketlösung die handelt wuchtiges Paket
aber einstelliger Milliarden Betrag das
heißt es wird sich in Grenzen hat er
hätte aber klar sagen können wir machen
einen gewissen nicht Turnaround aber wir
sind bereit uns auch in dieser Lage dem
anzupassen unter dem was Scholz immer
die Regierung der Tat nennt eine
Solidarität der Tat das hatte er jetzt
gerade in der Europa Rede gesagt das hat
Lindner dezidiert nicht gemacht weil die
Geschäftsgrundlage der FDP und das ist
das systemische Problem darin besteht
dieser linken Fraktion sie sprechen ja
immer die FDP von einer linken Koalition
im kleinen gewissermaßen aus Grünen und
SPD gewissermaßen die bürgerliche
wirtschaftsliberale können sozusagen
neoliberale Position entgegenzuhalten
keine weiteren Ausgaben und an diesem
Punkt ist natürlich ich sage das hat der
Ausfall eines Kanzlers der sich
tatsächlich auf den Standpunkt stellt
übrigens nach Meseberg das war ja schon
in einer Weise unverblümt wie er sagte
ich bin die Regierung der Tat und er
fände es muss natürlich Wurst machen man
kann sich bei Scholz eigentlich immer
darauf verlassen am Schluss kommt die
journalistenbeschimpfung auf eine kluge
Frage von Frau Dunst sagt dir einfach
für mich ist das ein Kompliment wenn sie
als Journalisten gar nicht mitkriegen
das wir etwas tun das muss man sich mal
auf der Zunge zergehen das sagt dir wenn
sie es nicht merken haben wir alles
gemacht aber er realisiert gar nicht und
das ist sein Dilemma mit Harbeck das in
einer solchen historischen
Krisensituation in der wir sind zu der
Tat die bisher übrigens auch nicht
Erfolg ist auch die Kommunikation gehört
er hat es bis heute nicht geschafft und
das ist auch übrigens die große
Verzweiflung in der SPD hat ja alles
versucht er ist ins Fernsehen gegangen
ist permanent on the record gewesen er
hat es nicht geschafft irgendwie die
Bevölkerung zu erreichen beziehungsweise
die neue Grundlage einer Koalition zu
schaffen in der es viel mehr auf
Solidarität ankommt eigentlich eine
grundsozialdemokratische Frage das
schafft er bisher nicht er müsste nur
zwei Sachen er müsste ganz klar direkt
da die finanziell schwachen entlasten
und deutlich machen und ich glaube mit
großer Zustimmung und Teil der Bürger er
müsste sagen die starken Schultern
brauchen keine Entlastung im Gegenteil
sie sind sogar bereit vielleicht noch zu
einer Belastung sie sind bereit
vielleicht eine einmalige
vermögensarbeit das wäre die Aufgabe die
leistungsscholz nicht und das ist das
Problem also wenn sich stolz zugute hält
die Journalisten haben sich mitbekommen
was wir jetzt alles besprochen haben und
das war eine Leistung der Regierung
erinnern ein bisschen an die
koalitionsverhandlung vom letzten Herbst
wo ja auch vieles hinter verschlossenen
Türen tatsächlich geblieben ist bis es
entschieden wurde jetzt
tritt etwas mehr pflegehaftigkeit im
politischen Alltag auf man streitet sich
auch auf offener Bühne das ist ein Stück
weit jetzt wieder eingefangen wird das
in Zukunft der Streit der Konflikt viel
öffentlicher werden in der
Ampelkoalition
das schwierige bei übersetzen über die
Zukunft ist ja immer das man es nicht
wissen kann also ja gut ist auch vor dem
Hintergrund dass ich gerade an also ich
habe Diskussionen auch gewundert dass
die SPD das gemacht hat weil das ist ja
ein Problem das im Kern in der Sache
liegt also wie konstruiert man diese
Umlage mit dem man auch Unternehmen
unterstützt dies gar nicht brauchen und
das haben die vorher gesehen das wussten
die dass das so ist und haben gesagt wir
kriegen das durch kommuniziert weil wir
eben sagen können 90 Prozent kommt in
der richtigen Tasche an und 10%
Streuverluste ist in so einer Lage
hinzunehmen das war die Vereinbarung
zwischen Wirtschaftsministerium und
Kanzleramt und dann kriegt die
Öffentlichkeit das Spiels und es gibt
die übliche Empörungswelle und dann
steigt der SPD-Vorsitzende der das
gewiss nicht ohne Scholz Segen getan hat
so hart ein gegen haarweg also ganz
typisch Politik eigentlich ein
sachliches Problem dass man dann
runterbricht auf eine Person um eben
diese Vorteil zu bedienen der Mann kann
nur gut reden also sozusagen die die
böse Seite images und dann das schon
beschriebene Revanche faul das
hundertprozentig auch nicht ohne Ansage
havix hinter den Kulissen ging und das
fand ich schon interessant dass die SPD
das nötig hat das muss ich schon sagen
in so einer Situation wo er keine
Kleinigkeiten verhandelt werden macht
man sich Sorgen wie kriegt man die die
Grünen vom hohen Ross runter und das ist
darf eigentlich im Moment nicht die
primäre Sorge sein ein Hintergrund
räumbereich ist ja auch dass manche
Koalitionspartner nervös werden wegen
ihrer schlechten Umfragewerte da gibt es
jetzt am 9 Oktober auch noch eine
Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen
möglicherweise ist das einer der Gründe
dafür dass man sich jetzt in der
Öffentlichkeit ab und zu mal vermöbelt
könnte es sein da ja die nächste
Landtagswahl erst bei dem nächsten Jahr
ist das ist dann in der Hinsicht was die
Verträglichkeit die Berechenbarkeit auch
die Kompromissfähigkeit in der Ampel
angeht ist nach dem 9 Oktober besser
wird sicherlich ein wenig also diese
Wahl ist definitiv also Niedersachsen
als SPD-Hochburg eine unglaublich
wichtige Wahl die auch zeigen wird wie
angeschlagen die Partei prinzipiell es
sollte überall verlieren und ich glaube
das Szenario wenn die SPD verliert ist
kann durchaus zu Chaos innerhalb der
ganzen Partei und der Basis führen aber
dementsprechend gerade vielleicht die
Spitze gegen die Grünen die in Umfragen
zurzeit zwei bis drei Prozent verlieren
die SPD führt knapp glaube ich ist
gerade als Parteivorsitzender klingen
bei aufgestellt um diese Spitzen zu
auszuschießen sehr sehr gewollt aber
trotzdem überraschend dass man sich so
bedroht fühlt angesichts dass die SPD
trotz der hohen Kritik an dem Kanzler
mit Stefan weil in Führung liegt zurzeit
wie sind das hat das für Auswirkungen
auf das beste Verhältnis in der
Koalition diese Umfragen Moment stehen
die Grünen relativ gut an die FDP kämpft
um ihr parlamentarisches überleben die
SPD sitzt in Wiesbaden ja bisher noch in
der Regierung hat ja eigentlich auch
einen sehr
populären und sehr profilierten
Ministerpräsidenten der jetzt kämpfen
muss ist das
auch in so eine Art Vorbote für die
Wahlen die sonst noch anstehen dass man
möglicherweise sich gerade aufgrund
dieser zum Teil ja sehr schlechten
Umfrageergebnisse da völlig neu
positioniert in der Ampelkoalition und
lässt diesen Streit dann zum Tower zum
Dauerbrenner macht naja also ich finde
halt was man im Moment beobachten kann
bei Stefan weil der in Hannover mit
regiert dort eine rot-schwarze
Landesregierung an für zusammen mit
Bernd Althusmann ich finde man sieht im
Moment ganz deutlich die Schwierigkeit
die er hat landespolitische Themen auch
eine landespolitische SPD Erzählung
gegen die großen bundespolitischen
Themen zu setzen ich finde er agiert da
tatsächlich nicht geschickt ich finde er
setzt dort keine ja narrative ist immer
so ein furchtbares Wort finde ich aber
ich finde er setzt dort keine klar
erkennbaren Ideen wie man eigentlich an
Punkte rangehen will ich finde man merkt
im durchaus an wie sehr auch damit
hadert auf den Bund zu warten auf
Entscheidungen aus dem Bund zu warten
und erst dann reagieren zu können ich
halte das wirklich für sehr unglücklich
und nächstes Jahr stehen zwei wirklich
große wichtige Landtagswahlen ins Haus
das ist in Hessen das ist in Bayern das
sind gerade auch in Bayern große
Industrieländer auch in Bayern sieht man
eine große Nervosität in Hessen gibt es
das wird interessant zu sehen wer da
vielleicht bundespolitisch noch
hinwechselt auch wieder den Versuch dort
in die Vorhand zu kommen
letztendlich finde ich ist das der
falsche Ansatz ich finde im Moment ist
es so dass die Parteien wenn sie
erkennbar sein wollen aus ihrer eigenen
Erzählung hinaus klar erkennbar auch für
ihre potenziellen Wähler Klientel ihre
Ideen präsentieren müssen ohne in diesen
Wettstreit Gedanken zu gehen und sich
Nickeligkeiten dann auch gegenseitig zu
unterbreiten weil ich finde was man
nicht vergessen darf sie haben eben das
Stichwort Gesellschaft genannt und das
ist ja finde ich ein zentraler Punkt
dieser Ampelkoalition arbeitet ja jetzt
nicht in einem Vakuum aus Parteipolitik
aus einem Vakuum aus Bundesregierung
vielleicht noch mit ein paar
professionellen journalistischen
BeobachterInnen und Beobachtern sondern
es geht ja auch um die Frage wie wird
das zurückgebunden an die Gesellschaft
wie neben Bürgerinnen und Bürger das war
und da sind die Zahlen die es dazu gibt
absolut verheerende deutsche Beamtenbund
hat heute was veröffentlicht zum Thema
29 Prozent der Befragten haben Vertrauen
in einen handlungsfähigen Staat im
Vergleich zu 45% im Vorjahr das heißt
man sieht vertrauensverluste wenn es
verschiedene Umfragen gibt von größeren
Instituten die Fragen welche Partei ist
denn eigentlich im Moment dazu am besten
geeignet uns produktiv aus dieser Krise
rauszuführen da ist die überwältigende
Mehrheit der Befragten sagt keine Partei
und das kann ja
niemanden freuen in dieser Koalition und
deswegen glaube ich ist es wichtig dass
die Koalition sich zusammenrauft
letztendlich ist es ja kein geholfen in
diesen Zentimeter weisen Geländegewinn
ist jetzt ein sehr militärisches Wort
aber in diesen Zentimeter weisen
vielleicht auch aufmerksamkeitsgewinnen
ich glaube es geht darum jetzt eine
gemeinsame Idee zu formulieren das
dritte Entlastungspaket kann finde ich
nur in erster Schritt sein um mal wieder
in gemeinsames Handeln
zusammenraufen jetzt dann konkret
bedeutet das ja was passiert eigentlich
jetzt in dem kalten oder heißen Herbst
je nach Sichtweise ob man die
Temperaturen in den Gebäuden nimmt oder
möglicherweise die politischen Konflikte
wenn so wenige Menschen Parteien
vertrauen was Frau Lindner gerade
zitiert hat handlungsfähiger Staat 29
Prozent wo muss da eigentlich die Ampel
dann ansetzen wie muss dieser kalte oder
heiße Herbst dann angegangen werden was
ist da notwendig ich glaube ich würde
nicht das Prinzip wählen sich
zusammenzuraufen und wieder sehr viele
Kompromisse zu finden sondern gerade
eigentlich das starke soziale Bündnis
dass die SPD und die Grünen Willen in
dieser Koalition auszunutzen denn es
geht definitiv um die Finanzierungsfrage
und auch wie sehr man das Ego das
Finanzministers betrachtet das heißt
Thema übergewinnsteuer oder wie man
inwieweit man die Schuldenbremse
aussetzt im nächsten Jahr um die Bürger
weiterhin zu entlasten als auch
Deckel für Gaspreise deswegen wurde ja
auch der portugiesische Ministerium
spanische Regierungschef eingeladen um
eigentlich diesen leichten Druck
auszuüben was sehr hoffentlich in den
nächsten Wochen auch dann diskutiert
wird also die SPD wäre gut beraten wenn
sie in dem Moment vielleicht ihre eigene
Agenda setzt anstatt auf so
Kompromisslösung zu setzen die
vielleicht für zwei drei Monate
funktionieren aber am Ende wieder
relativ
naja also im nächsten Jahr weiterhin die
Krisen einfach nur aufschieben also die
Klimakrise steht danach trotzdem noch an
wir werden auch mit Blick auf Corona
einen interessanten Winter haben das
heißt für die Gaskrise jetzt punktuell
für Monat zu denken finde ich ist eine
falsche Ansatz Alexander wie geht
eigentlich das mit den begrenzten
Ressourcen die der Staat hat
Steuermittel also für Staatsausgaben die
jetzt notwendig sind in
entlastungspaketen um soziale Unwuchten
zu beseitigen der wird da ein großer
Verteilungskampf eine regelrechte
verteilungsschlacht einsetzen weil nicht
alle Ansprüche nicht alle Erwartungen
können befriedigt werden selbst wenn man
jetzt noch sehr viel mehr Geld in die
Hand nimmt vielleicht sogar die
Schuldenbremse weiter lockert also das
mit den nicht alle Wünsche können
erfüllt werden ist ja immer im Leben so
und ich staune immer darüber zu sagen
jetzt müsste man die Ausgaben es ist
noch nie so viel Geld vom Staat
ausgegeben wie jetzt also die die
letzten Jahre hat der der Staat ist in
allen merkeljahren ist der
Bundeshaushalt gewachsen
der Corona ist also massig gewachsen
jetzt wird wieder und das lustige ist ja
dass man dieses Geld gar nicht
ausgegeben kriegt also die die Ampel hat
ja alles noch zusammengekehrt was die
große Koalition die flüchtlingsreserve
von Schäuble 22 Milliarden gefunden und
jetzt in den Haushalt rein auch die
ganzen Schulprogramme also der Staat
setzt riesige Programme auf und es gibt
überhaupt nicht mehr die Möglichkeit
dass das irgendwie abfließt ja oder die
denken Sie an die legendären 400.000
Wohnungen die Shorts im im Wahlkampf
versprochen hat die scheitern nicht an
Geld die scheitert dass die Leute nicht
mehr da sind und die Rohstoffe also
diese Idee man könne in Berlin irgendwie
sagen ich stelle ein riesigen Sack Geld
und dann müsst ihr euch alle keine
Sorgen mehr machen das funktioniert
wahrscheinlich noch nie funktioniert
also bei Corona war das ja auch sehr
auffällig gewesen trotzdem ist es ja
trotzdem so oder ich gebe ihm recht
ehrlich gesagt
Essbereiche gibt wo Geld noch existiert
wo es nicht abgerufen worden ist weil
wir wissen das wurde ja auch ein großes
Thema wir haben zum Teil gar nicht die
Arbeitskräfte die beispielsweise manche
der Projekte die Tat umsetzen können das
war ein Thema jetzt in diese Berg also
berufliche Fortbildung und überhaupt
Ausbildung aber wir werden natürlich im
Winter und darum geht der Streit direkte
Bedürfnisse haben die kommen mit Herbst
und Winter auf uns zu wo direkt
Zuwendungen von finanziell schwachen
Bedürftigen da sind und das Hauptproblem
dieser Koalition und das verstehe ich
auch wirklich nicht warum eine SPD eine
eine grüne Partei übrigens aber auch die
FDP nicht in der Lage ist wir haben
einen Fehler von Anfang an gemacht die
lustigerweise den ihn jetzt müsste
mittlerweile sehr Friedrich Merz unter
die Nase reiben dass er nämlich sagt
warum geben wir ein energiegeld von 300
Euro für alle Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer aus
und machen es nicht direkt den
zugänglich die es wirklich bedürfen und
wirklich dann wirklich weißen ganz
anderen Umfang das ist das eigentliche
Problem ich glaube die wirkliche direkte
Zuwendung die noch ganz in anderen
Umfang kommt wenn man nur den den
seelsorbern gewissermaßen Glauben
schenkt dann sind existenzielle Ängste
da Leute die Angst haben dass sie ihre
Wohnung verlieren und dergleichen und
wenn das nicht adressiert wird also Olaf
Scholz seiner Solidarität der Tat oder
auch diesem äh der Regierung der Tat
oder als Regierung Tat Solidarität der
Tat oder auch dieses große Wort never
walk alone wenn er das nicht wirklich
umsetzt und klar macht hier werden den
wirklich Bedürftigen die Bedürfnisse die
Existenz sind
existenziell sind erfüllt dann glaube
ich wird es schwierig für ihn diesen
Anspruch aufrecht zu halten und das
glaube ich ist momentan das zentrale
Problem wird denn der Bevölkerung
genügend und auch richtig erklärt was da
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten auf
die Menschen zukommen können naja ich
glaube die Antwort dazu ist relativ
einfach nein also sonst hätte ich das ja
auch nicht gesagt
ich glaube der Punkt ist mit dem
zusammenraufen ich glaube was ich damit
auch sagen wollte und auch verbinde ist
eine Bestandsaufnahme ist eine
Orientierung das heißt wo stehen wir
welche Problemanalyse gibt es und wo
wollen wir eigentlich hin also welche
Ziele verfolgen wir sowohl in der
Sicherheitspolitik welche Ziele
verfolgen wir in der
energiewirtschaftspolitik in der
energiesicherungspolitik
Habeck macht das zum Teil aber ich
glaube auch dass dieses Modell habe
jetzt erstmal gewissen Schaden genommen
hat und auch an gewisse Grenzen gestoßen
ist ich glaube schon dass natürlich weiß
man nicht was in der Zukunft noch kommt
ich glaube aber dass es das Scholz in
dieser Situation
ich weiß nicht ob es noch mal lernt ich
glaube aber dort nicht ausreichend
kommunikativ unterwegs ist ich glaube es
geht ja auch darum im Moment eine
gewisse emotionale Verunsicherung zu
bedienen
das ist natürlich nicht alles aber die
großen Linien zu zeigen da gibt es jetzt
am Wochenende noch mal Interview das ist
gelinde gesagt das was ich von ihm
erwarte auch Deutschlands Rolle auch
innerhalb der Europäischen Union auch
Interdependenzen die es zum Beispiel auf
dem Energiemarkt ja gibt zu geben also
das erwarte ich jetzt ungefähr ja
eigentlich ja ein knappes Jahr nach der
nach der Bundestagswahl ja wie viel
Offenheit ist da möglich was muss
eigentlich müsste man im Moment noch
sagen was müsste eigentlich da erklärt
werden also den Menschen die
existenziellen Ängste zu nehmen die
wirklich ganz hart auf Kante genäht sind
aber ja vielleicht auch den den es
besser geht zu sagen ihr werdet in jedem
Fall Wohlstandsverluste erleiden die wir
nicht ausgleichen können
muss das in diese Richtung gehen oder
was was muss jetzt passieren und wird es
da auch wenn die Antwort ganz klar war
nein es wird nicht genügend erklärt da
nicht wirklich eine Besinnung in der
Ampel geben ich glaube das Olaf Scholz
durch die Chance hat sich dieser
Ehrlichkeit zu bedienen diese multiplen
Krisen als
Prioritätensetzung zu bezeichnen das
heißt was ist eigentlich gerade das
Thema und wie kann man auch als
Sozialdemokratische Partei sich nehmen
profilieren und ich glaube das muss man
auch wenn man einer Koalition ist tun
dementsprechend noch mal das Olaf Scholz
sich eventuell für eine übergewinnsteuer
etc einsetzen könnte und das
Kommunizieren könnte auch was eigentlich
nötig wäre und gerade diesen Teil der
Bevölkerung zu entlasten und
gleichzeitig zu appellieren es geht hier
auch es geht um eine Frage der
Solidarität es geht darum ob wir allen
Bürgern das gleiche überweisen allen
Arbeitnehmer das gleich beweisen oder ob
wir da Prioritäten setzen und diese
Debatte auch mit zu bestärken um
vielleicht eine schnellere
Lösungsfindung anzustreben wäre ein Weg
den ich interessant fände und ich glaube
mit Blick darauf wie gut Ehrlichkeit bei
Habeck funktioniert hat und ich glaube
auch dass das weiterhin funktionieren
würde man kann auch solche Situationen
solche Momente in dem einen Image einen
Schaden annimmt wieder mit Ehrlichkeit
in die Öffentlichkeit kommunizieren das
ist etwas wo ich eine Chance wohl auf
Scholz sehe trotz hanseatischer kühle
und ich würde gerne vielleicht an der
Stelle noch was ergänzen man darf ja
auch nicht vergessen wir schauen jetzt
wieder auf die Regierung aber ich finde
es lohnt sich an dieser Stelle durchaus
noch mal in die gesellschaftliche
Perspektive auch in die
parteienpolitische Perspektive
zurückzugehen weil auf dem politischen
Rändern auf beiden politischen Rändern
sind im Moment stark politische Akteure
unterwegs die mit ganz einfachen
Erklärungsansätzen mit auch sehr
emotionalen Erklärungsansätzen unterwegs
sind die auch klare Interessen haben
ihre eigene Position stärken wollen da
ist zum einen die Linkspartei die für
die kommende Woche zu Demonstration
aufruft da ist die AFD die in der
vergangenen Woche tatsächlich die
Hauptstadtpresse erstmal eingeladen hat
um ihr protestkonzept die
proteststrategie in Teilen oder
zumindest im Grundzügen zu erklären das
heißt es gibt meiner Ansicht nach im
Moment auch genügend radikale Kräfte mit
einfachen Antworten deshalb finde ich
ist die Mitte und besonders
herausgefordert das heißt die
Ampelkoalition aber auch zum Beispiel
eine CDU um zu zeigen wie diese
auf multiplen Krisen bewältigt werden
können in einem Wettstreit der Ideen und
dann halt aber auch zu zeigen auch in
einem Regierungshandeln ich würde gerne
noch mal wieder den Stachel löten die
Vorstellung die auch hier am Tisch
geäußert wird man kann jetzt eine
übergewinnsteuer erheben um jedem das
gleiche auszuzahlen ich glaube es ist
doch komplexer wen würde man denn da
besteuern also zum Beispiel die Leute
die gerade richtig viel Geld verdienen
sind Leute die Windparks betreiben weil
wir einen Strommarkt haben wo der
Gaspreis auch das Entgelt für den Wind
festlegt so der Wind kostet aber das
gleiche wie immer mich fast nichts also
die Leute verdienen sich eine goldene
Nase jetzt gehen sie zu diesem Wind
Leuten und sagen das ist aber moralisch
falsch das sage ich warum nichts gemacht
wir haben die spekuliert und so wir
machen einfach weiter unser Windstrom
und da sagt man ja aber ihr habt ja nur
Glück und dann sage ich ihnen haben wir
gar nicht wir haben euch immer gesagt
fossile Energien sind Mist wir haben
euch immer gesagt die Abhängigkeit von
Russland ist Mist hätten alle Leute
Windparks zu essen wir gar nicht in der
Tinte so und können den Leuten wieder
vorwerfen dass sie moralisch böse sind
noch können Sie ihn vorwerfen spekuliert
zu haben und dann sagen sie wir nehmen
euch trotzdem euer Geld weg dann sagen
die Wind Leute ist aber schade weil wir
wollten noch mehr Windparks bauen mit
unserem Geld das wir gerade verdienen
also sie genommen in ganz seltsame
verteilungsdiskussion die auch immer
ökonomische Folgen haben die vielleicht
gar nicht den Zielen entsprechend diese
erreichen wollen und ich möchte auch
noch mal sagen wir haben doch schon
Inflation also wir haben schon Inflation
es ist schon so viel Geld unterwegs das
alles immer teurer wird wir haben schon
eine Situation dass wir für die
Infrastruktur die Regierung bauen will
die Leute nicht mehr haben also wir
haben doch schon eine Situation der
Überhitzung weil wir ja schon auf die
vorigen Krisen dadurch reagiert haben
dass die Zinsen Null waren und dass das
Geld nur so ausgeht also diese Idee
also diese sehr kurzschlussgerechtigkeit
Krisenbewältigung viel Geld vom Staat
ich glaube das ist es nicht
ganz sicher ich möchte nur ganz kurz
darauf noch mal reagieren das heißt also
der Kanzler erweckt immer den Eindruck
er will es allen Recht machen never walk
alone das heißt das wird auch da nicht
funktionieren und ist ein also da würde
ich stolz verteidigen weil you never
walk alone heißt nicht ich will es allen
Recht machen das heißt du bist nicht
alleine und er sagt auch er sagt auch
nicht ich zementiere jeden sozialen
Status in dieser Gesellschaft auf ewig
sondern er sagt oder er will damit sagen
wenn jemand in eine existenzielle Krise
gerät dann wird der Staat ihm helfen und
das finde ich richtig und das ist auch
geplant also ich meine das Wohngeld wird
um eine heizkomponente erwärmt erweitert
also die Leute die wirklich drohen raus
zu fliegen fliegen nicht raus da sind
wir ja da Chor das also das ist ja klar
aber wir reden ja darüber hinaus muss
man noch mehr Umverteilung machen und xx
kommt auch viel von Leuten die immer
schon dafür haben es ist doch ein
Problem und das ist das zentrale Problem
es geht gar nicht nur um die Frage dass
immer mehr ausgegeben wird es ist die
zentrale Frage an wen dieses Geld geht
und das Grundproblem einer
Sozialdemokratie bestand darin übrigens
das ganze Grundproblem der
bundesrepublikanischen Geschichte die
letztlich immer von wachstumsen von
Wachstums die von Wachstums ja die immer
von Wachstums gewinnen profitierte es
nie erlebt hat dass wir in eine Zeit
geraten sind in der wir mit absoluter
Inflation zu tun haben mit nichtwachstum
mit einer Rezession und die Frage auf
doch gerade weil der Haushalt nicht in
dem Maße wächst dass wir nicht in alle
Richtungen verteilen können sondern in
Teilen gezwungen sind genau zu gucken wo
es hingeht und das ist mein Bedauern
dass die Sozialdemokratie sich nicht
traut zu sagen erhebliche Teile der
Gesellschaft brauchen gerade nichts ein
energiegeld was an alle geht
interessanterweise nicht an Rentner und
Studenten wo man sich fragt es gibt
sozial Schwache Rentner es gibt aber
auch sehr gut situierte Rentner das ist
im Prinzip you never walk alone nicht zu
tragen weil das ja die Frage beantworten
müsste you never walk alone ist doch
nicht notwendigerweise nur einen Start
adressiert da gebe ich ihn ja völlig
Recht der Alexander sondern die Frage
ist doch auch wer hat eigentlich in den
letzten 70 Jahren in diesem Staat sehr
gut gelebt ich sag mal ganz konkret auch
an ein Teil der Wirtschaft gerichtet wer
hat in den letzten 30 40 50 Jahren seit
72 gibt es einen extensiven
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit Russland wer
hat übrigens auch in den letzten 16
Jahren wir kritisieren nur die Regierung
Merkel durchaus zu Recht wer hat in den
letzten 16 Jahren immer dafür plädiert
auch die wunderbaren gasgewinne mit
Russland zu machen das war ein
erheblicher Teil der Wirtschaft die
Grundfrage besteht doch darin warum
fragt man eine solche gesellschaftliche
Solidarität nicht ab und das bedauere
ich dass die SPD und auch der Kanzler in
einer solchen Situation wir haben die
eine solche historische Lage gehabt dass
er nicht in der Lage ist zu sagen ich
glaube viele in der bürgerlichen
Bevölkerung durch außerhalb der
Alexander sie schütteln so ihren Kopf
eine einer eher bürgerlichen
Anführungszeichen Meinung glaube ich
dass die besser situierten erheblichen
Maß erkannt haben dass sie erstens
nichts bekommen wollen sogar zum Teil
und dass sie sogar bereit wären in
dieser Situation vielleicht sogar
entlastenausgleich zu Gunsten der
Schwachen zu leisten das erwarte ich
eigentlich auch von der
sozialdemokratischen Regierung ich
wollte daher an Alexander widersprechen
weil sie jetzt auf dieses Instrument des
wohngelds eingegangen sind aber das
erreicht ja nicht alle also das heißt
das ist jetzt der Fokus auf Privatleute
ja da wird geholfen in der Ausweitung
sozusagen ist
bezugskreises dann vielleicht auch in
der Ausweitung der Zahlung aber auch
Betriebe auch gerade kleine Betriebe
haben ja diese Schwierigkeiten mit hohen
Energiekosten auch relativ schnell weil
dort auch nicht unbedingt auf
Nachzahlung Abrechnung zum Beispiel von
der Hausverwaltung gewartet werden muss
da ist der Druck ziemlich stark da und
teilweise wird ja auch gespiegelt dass
diese Idee dass der Staat dann was für
mich tut mich alimentiert als jemanden
der den Betrieb immer auch profitabel
führen konnte dass diese Idee dann auch
nicht unbedingt auf große Freude stößt
auch bei denjenigen man sieht es ja
teilweise dann halt auch schon die
eigentlich Zugriff hätten auf bestimmte
sozialpolitische Leistungen in der
Grundsicherung im Alter sieht man das
teilweise auch bei
kindergeldleistung dann aus Scham aus
Trotz vielleicht aus nicht wissen
bestimmte Dinge nicht beantragt werden
also von daher ist glaube ich die Frage
nicht nur auf staatliche Instrumente zu
schauen sondern wirklich auch die
Energiepreise an sich und als solches in
den Fokus zu nehmen was wo ich finde das
ist nicht nur diskutierenswert wie es
habe ich gesagt oder ich glaube das ist
im Moment auch wirklich notwendig
es ist das Stichwort schon gefallen
Opposition da gibt es die
radikalisierten oder sich
radikalisierenden Ränder die diese
Situation jetzt
ausnutzen wollen Stichwort Wut
anzustacheln und es gibt eben diese
Opposition der Mitte der die Union im
Bundestag Alexander wie positionieren
sich die denn im Moment machen die das
richtig es ist ja eigentlich auch eine
Zeit in der die Opposition sich gut
profilieren könnte wie ist diese Rolle
zu sehen in diesem ganzen Kontext
zwischen einer ganz radikalen Opposition
auf der einen Seite und einer Ampel die
immer wieder Flanken öffnet die man
hineinstoßen kann ich finde dass die
Union das bemerkenswert schnell
hingekriegt hat weil man dachte ja die
haben 16 Jahre regiert die können das
gar nicht mehr und das können sie doch
weil der Unterschied zum Beispiel dass
man in der Kritik hart ist wenn es
wichtig ist aber gleichzeitig aus
staatspolitischer Vernunft Dinge
mitträgt das ist ja das was eine Mitte
Opposition ausmacht was auch die SPD
übrigens gut konnte als sie noch in
Opposition war schon länger her was hat
die SPD immer ausgezeichnet und die CDU
kann das auch also sieht man März trägt
die zeitenwände mit das ist ist ja keine
kleine Sache trägt das voll mit und März
hat zum Beispiel auf die Frage liefern
wir genug Waffen in die Ukraine wo der
sozialdemokratische Teil der Regierung
Angriffsfläche bot ein
Bundestagsbeschluss eigentlich durch
seinen Druck erwirkt der sagt ja wir
liefern auch schwere Waffen und hat Frau
Lamprecht und Herrn Scholzen in Zugzwang
gesetzt also ich finde das machen die
auf der Ebene schon geschickt jetzt
könnte man sagen die haben auch
Vorschläge zum Entlastungspaket
vorgestellt wo man sagt ja in der
Opposition muss man nicht so genau
nachrechnen oder in dem neuen Papier was
die jetzt auf der zugspitzen Tagung
gemacht da besteht wir müssen
Exportweltmeister bleiben aber wir
müssen uns ganz unabhängig von China
machen also dann gibt es
Zielkonflikte die man aber in der
Opposition durchgehen lassen kann würde
ich sagen es gibt auch finde ich da
interessante auch nur sierungen in der
Positionierung gerade auch von Herrn
märz also ein interessantes Thema das
ist mir heute aufgefallen noch mal im
Bezug auf energiekontext dass ich
Friedrich Merz hinstellt mit
entschlossener Stimme sagt ja wir müssen
jetzt alle Quellen anzapfen dann zählt
er auf natürlich irgendwie Braunkohle
Steinkohle dann geht da irgendwie auf
Biomasse zum Beispiel noch ein spricht
dann zum Schluss von der Kernenergie die
man gerne behalten möchte vielleicht
sogar noch weiter ausbauen oder auch
reaktivieren möchte und dann fand ich es
interessant weil ein Punkt fehlt da
tatsächlich in dieser Auflistung das ist
nämlich das Wort Fracking was er
vielleicht subsumiert hat unter dem
Thema alle Energiequellen aber auf
einmal taucht es nicht mehr auf obwohl
man gestrichen
zwei Landespolitiker genau aus dem
Bundesländern wo entweder Landtagswahl
ist plus Fracking stattfinden kann das
ist Niedersachsen wo er also man gesagt
hat schlichter Hinweis das ist im Moment
in Deutschland verboten und Thomas
Strobel der aus Baden-Württemberg kommt
wo das auch teilweise eine Rolle spielen
kann also etwas theoretischer als in
Niedersachsen der sagt das ist eine Idee
die uns ins Nirvana führ so hat er sich
Ende Juli geäußert so und da hatte ich
dann schon das Gefühl aha huch auf
einmal ist man dann doch nicht mehr so
ganz mit breiter Brust obwohl es dann
noch wiederum Landespolitiker gibt wie
Michael Kretschmer in Sachsen auch kein
Fracking stattfindet auch nicht
stattfinden wird er sagt so was ist top
Idee also
auch welche Rolle diese und die
Opposition fallen die Union Spiel wird
sie auch immer so eine Art
zustimmungsreserven für die
Ampelkoalition sein wenn es spitz auf
Knopf steht wenn ganz schwierige
Entscheidungen treffen sind das war ja
keine ganzen Fragen rund um den
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine auch so
gewesen dass also Sie die richtige
Oppositionsrolle diese
gegen die Politik generell zu sein um
eine Alternative anzubieten zu aktuellen
Regierungspolitik gar nicht so richtig
ausspielen kann zumindest in den
absehbarer Zeit solange diese Krisen
andauern Alexander zustimmen dass das in
der Tat sehr bemerkt wird ist dass es so
schnell geklappt hat da ein Gewicht zu
finden zwischen in den richtigen menten
vielleicht auch mit eher populistischen
Forderungen die Aufmerksamkeit auf sich
zu ziehen aber ernsten fragen
die irgendwie wenig Parteipolitik
bedürften zu sagen okay da stellen wir
uns mit der hinter weil es gerade um
etwas Wichtiges geht und ich glaube
damit hätte die Union sich auch kein
Gefallen getan gerade bei der
waffenlieferungsfrage wenn man sich da
jetzt irgendwie quer gestellt hätte und
eine Sache wird aber gerne bei Frau
Lindner hinzufügen ich finde es
interessant dass die das gerade die CDU
darauf setzt mit so kleinen Forderungen
wie zum Beispiel Kernenergie worauf man
sich ja sehr stürzt und nämlich nicht
das Fracking wobei ich auch glaube das
konnte November wieder so Vorschläge in
die Gesellschaft reinzuwerfen die nur
populistisch auf Twitter diskutiert
werden oder sie sich dann ist
chauffieren oder bestimmte
Journalistenpreise und da irgendwie so
ein Schwerpunkt draufsetzen ihren
Kampagnen und man hat das Gefühl hat
okay hier merkt man dass die Relevanz
der
Opposition vielleicht nicht so groß ist
bei so großen Fragen und man sich da
auch durchaus zwischendurch verrennen
kann und vielleicht andreas Scheuer mit
dem 3 x 3 x 3 nämlich 3 reaktivieren
drei Anlassen drei neue bauen Stichwort
Kernkraft vielleicht auch wieder zeigt
vielleicht jetzt auch gut dass die Union
gerade mal Opposition erfährt ich
wundere mich ein bisschen über das große
wundern hier am Tisch über die Fähigkeit
der Opposition also der cdu/csu diese
knapp 27 28 Prozent wieder in Umfragen
zu erzielen das ist in dem Fall vor
allem auch dem desaströsen
Erscheinungsbild der Regierung
geschuldet wenn eine Regierung die
Opposition selber besorgt dann ist es
auch kein Wunder und das ist das
Grundproblem dieser Koalition und da
wird es noch viel fundamentaler für die
Union zu einem Minimalwert sage ich mal
zurückzukehren wir haben doch und das
macht das eigentlich wenn man dieser
Koalition aus wir haben die Situation
dass die zufallssituation des
vergangenen Herbstes wir sind ja bald
schon wieder sie haben es angekündigt
mit Blick auf das einjährige dieser Wahl
des September 2021 das eine reine ich
sag das mal Zufalls Konjunktur der SPD
geschuldet dem völligen Versagen einer
cdu/csu woher Laschet der falsche
Kandidat aufgestellt wurde im Lachen im
Wahlkampf alles zu nicht gemacht und von
einem Markus Söder so attackiert wurde
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit ganz
gänzlich so nicht gemacht wurde die sie
normalerweise hätten nie verlieren
dürfen zweitens einfach sagen von
nationalena beerburg dieser Umstand hat
Olaf Scholz zu einer ausgesprochenen bis
dato nie vorhandenen Kanzler Mehrheit
von 25% gemacht wenn eine solche
Koalition plötzlich wieder so desaströst
da steht dann ist es kein Wunder dass
die Union sofort wieder auf diese 27 28
Prozent ansteigt die sind nicht Herr
März geschuldet der März Werte sind
ausgesprochen schwach bisher kann keine
Rede davon sein dass dieser Politiker
Typus überhaupt noch ankommt jetzt ist
bloß ja eigentlich dramatische Punkt wir
haben wieder eine Lage in der unter
normalen Umständen sofort wieder die
eigentliche Konstellation die vor
anderthalb Jahren der Fall gewesen wäre
nämlich schwarz grün der Fall gewesen
wäre und dieses dieses Momentum ist die
große Verunsicherung einer SPD Scholz
hat bloß nach wie vor und das ist ein
Glück er hat die autosuggestive
Fähigkeit sich immer zu sagen ich habe
es immer geschafft ich habe
durchgehalten indem ich keine Fehler
gemacht habe das reicht jetzt nicht er
bloß ein großes Glück es gibt keinen
Grund warum diese Koalition nicht vier
Jahre durchhält er hat eigentlich alle
Gelegenheit auf Zeit zu spielen weil er
weiß die FDP ist mit dem Klammerbeutel
gepudert sie wird nie wieder diese Werte
kriegen weil die Union wieder der
klassische
was liberale die bürgerliche Referenz
ist und die Grünen würden auch nicht
wagen zur Union als dem nicht normalen
Partner überzulaufen weil niemand liebt
den Verräter vielleicht den Verrat also
das heißt Stolz hat noch diese drei
Jahre und unser Dilemma ist bloß dass
wir eine Koalition haben die unter
dieser Konfiguration eigentlich eine
zufallslage ist und bisher nicht
ansatzweise zu der Kraft gefunden hat
euch kommen müsste und das macht die
Stärke der Union aus aber die keine
exorbitante ist eine Union müsste in
dieser Situation alle mal wieder über 30
Prozent kommen damit wir sagen könnten
diese und Opposition ist stark also ich
sprach gar nicht über Stärke ich sprach
über inhaltliche Positionierung und das
und ich finde auch sowohl in dem anderen
zusammen sowohl ihre Beschreibung der
Regierung als der Opposition des
fehlerhaft weil die Ampel ist nicht
desaströs das stimmt doch gar nicht das
Interessante ist doch wir haben eine
Konstellation das ist eine Regierung
gibt in der Mitte gebildet wird und es
gäbe eine Alternative in der Mitte und
beide würden die Fundamente des Staates
nicht verändern und das ist kein
triviale Sache die ich hier sage genau
darauf setzt doch Wladimir Putin
Wladimir Putin setzt deshalb haben wir
doch diese Gas und Strom Probleme
ersetzt unsere Gesellschaften unter
Druck der hofft dass in Italien eine
bürgerliche Regierung kippt und eine
Rechtspopulistin kommt und dann wissen
wir nicht wie sie sich zur Ukraine
verhält dasselbe war wenn Frau Lemper in
Frankreich gewonnen hätte so selbst wenn
unsere Ampel wahnsinnig unter Druck
geriete was sie noch nicht ist und das
würde ein schwarz-grünes oder
grün-schwarz oder was immer würde sich
doch die Ukraine Politik gar nicht
wirklich ändern also diese Gesellschaft
Deutschland ist noch so stark
dass die Mitte das tatsächlich hält aber
das ist etwas
was man durchaus mal gut finden kann das
schwer in die Frage zu stellen die
wieder eine Zukunftsprojektion
beinhaltet
sehen Sie diese Konditionen als
alternativlos an nein nix ist
alternativlos warum das könnte auch
Jamaika geben oder sonst was das ist
doch alles möglich und das ich glaube
allerdings auch also Olaf Scholz ist
doch wirklich ein erfahrener Politiker
und das die Mechanismen bei uns sind
auch so dass sie den Kanzler Stützen
also es würde mich extrem wundern wenn
ich nicht vier Jahre durchhalten würden
das macht aber auch nichts weil die sind
ja gewählt das ist doch okay die ist ja
wie sie durchhalten das ist das
eigentliche Problem wir werden kein
Glück haben mit einer Koalition in
diesen Herausforderung nicht durch klare
politik besteht das ist doch zum Teil
hier das Problem
leider an der Stelle
merken sich für die nächste Sendung wir
müssen aufhören ich denke aber das ist
schon relativ klar geworden wie im
Moment der aktuelle Stand um die Ampel
ist ich be für mich bei Jasmin embarek
bei Nadine Lindner bei Albrecht von
Lukas und bei Robin Alexander liebe
Zuschauer nächstes
phönix-gesprächs Format ist am Montag um
22 Uhr unter den Linden mit Michaela
Polster
weiteres und aktuelles bei Phoenix der
Tag mit Alfred schier unter anderem ein
Statement von Robert Habeck der der
Roller der dieser Sendung ja auch eine
gewisse Rolle gespielt hat es gibt einen
fünften LNG Terminal in Deutschland also
fünf anlerntestellen für Flüssigkeiten
in den nächsten Jahren dazu wie er sich
äußern bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]